chris
slow time but not a slow time a point we
made last hour this is the time of year
when teams
everything's settled free agency they've
acquired their new players lost their
players filled their holes through the
draft ready to focus on the coming
season but it's an opportunity to look
at the guys that you have that you may
want to try to keep and there are plenty
of guys out there who need new contracts
at the quarterback position and one of
the themes that has come up in recent
weeks
when will a team
say
enough yeah we're not giving you 35
million right we're not giving you 30
million we're not even applying the
franchise tag go see what someone else
will pay you because no one else is
going to pay you anything close to what
you want and i feel like that day is
coming yeah no i i do think so too i
mean we've talked about it a lot uh
we've seen recent trends that have shown
teams uh that are very successful
whether they're in the super bowl win
the super bowl final four
they have quarterback friendly deals
whether it's tom brady or our guys on
rookie contracts we've seen a lot of
teams succeed that way and i'm with you
i think it's going to happen here real
soon i think the whole nfl is going to
realize it to where maybe it does affect
the qb market a little bit and brings it
back down to reality a little bit i got
no problem with the russell wilson's and
aaron rodgers and the ben roethlisberger
making what they're making but i will
say that i don't know necessarily that
guys like kirk cousins and jimmy
garoppolo should be making you know four
times the amount of money that tyron
matthews making or you know a guy like
you know michael bennett or whoever it
may be i don't think they're worth that
so that's something i'm interested to
see where it goes in the future
but i mean philosophically right the
quarterback is the most important player
on the field if you have a franchise
quarterback you are likely to contend
the challenge is paying that guy a
competitive rate and having enough money
left to address the other areas of your
team and ultimately what happens when
you have a quarterback who's making
market value or close to it you've got
other key players around him who are
making good money you sacrifice depth
that is the thing to keep in mind and
that's why the patriots have that edge
over other teams when they suffer an
injury the guy they put in more often
than not is a veteran player who is
making good money instead of some guy
that is being thrust into the limelight
who was a sixth round pick or a practice
squad guy who was called up this week
and that's where the weak spot emerges
where you can coach to that weakness and
exploit that one guy whether you're
trying to bust through the line to get
to the quarterback whether you're you
know i remember in super bowl 49 when
jeremy lane broke his arm and who was
the guy who came in feral simon came in
yeah you're right and and tom brady
targeted targeted targeted targeted
targeted yes that's the problem when you
have a lot of guys who are highly paid
yeah you get that one injury and the
replacement can't get it done and then
you are done yeah no i think that's
exactly it mike and that's why we've
seen new england be so successful right
they always manage injuries or anything
like that because they have great depth
at every position but yeah at the end of
the day it's hard to build a complete
roster when you're paying a guy such a
big chunk of your salary cap and you're
gonna have when you pay a guy that much
money yeah more times than not you're
gonna at least have one positional group
where you're gonna go
damn i wish we were a little bit better
there or a little deeper or a little had
a little bit better high-end talent
whatever it may be it's just uh you
can't have the perfect roster and this
is the things you gotta balance out
harold simon allowed two touchdowns in
that loss to the new england patriots
and
tom brady immediately went after him
again again again and again throughout
that game and without that injury maybe
the patriots don't win that super bowl
all right the reason we're talking about
this we have an exercise today chris
okay i have identified eight
quarterbacks that are within one or two
years of a new contract so
i i we're gonna identify which of these
guys aren't going to get their contract
i've set the over under at two and a
half okay i'm going to give you the
names and i want i want you to give me
your knee-jerk thought is this guy going
to get the long-term contract he wants
let's start with the two guys we talked
about last hour dak prescott carson
wentz do you believe they're both going
to get the long-term contract or does
one of them end up somewhere else
i think both get the long-term contract
i think the that both teams have uh come
to terms that these are their franchise
guys these are the guys they want to
lead them in the future sign sealed and
delivered
they will get a contract extension with
their current team
the range right now from derek carr 25
million per year to russell wilson at 35
million per year i think that range is
so broad it makes it hard to pinpoint
where some of these guys should land yes
where do you put prescott where do you
put wentz on that range of 25 to 35. i
think realistically i would say right
around that 30 mark again i think would
be fair you know i think at the very
least both guys yeah i think so i do
first of all i think carson wentz is
more talented than dak prescott i do i
think he's a better overall football
player he hasn't been able to stay
healthy i get that but carson wentz is
as big or bigger than dak prescott he
runs better than dak prescott and he's
got a better arm than dak prescott so i
give him the advantage there but doc
prescott has the advantage of saying
well i've been to the playoffs two out
of the three years i was a starter and
the one year i wasn't you know ezekiel
elliott was suspended six games and we
had a whole bunch of issues with our
team so i just look at this these two
guys both at a base level are gonna be
able to say we deserve as much as kirk
cousins or jimmy garoppolo in this
instance and i think at the very least
that's their low end right there 27 and
a half 8 28 million
prescott's best argument is i'm playing
in december in january carson wentz
isn't and i think we saw last year now
it's a small sample size but i think
prescott had an excellent game against
the seattle seahawks took on russell
wilson and beat him and
in that next game when the running game
wasn't there the way it usually is
usually the running game as stephen
jones told us last week is the st it's a
straw that stirs the drink the the drink
wasn't getting stirred by ezekiel elliot
against the rams but prescott still
played very well and maybe maybe that's
maybe that's the beginning of the
ascension we're going to see and maybe
from the cowboys perspective you lock
him in i'd say get him around 27.5
million give him the jimmy garoppolo
contract get him locked in now he can
make a bunch of other money doing other
things because he's the dallas cowboys
quarterback because maybe we're on the
front end of dak prescott really
becoming a great quarterback if what we
saw in the playoffs is an indication of
where he's headed yeah i think it is i
mean the last half of the year was i
thought pretty damn good with dak
prescott once he just got a little help
in the pass game with a guy like amari
cooper but you know hey what i always
look at for a franchise quarterback is
not always you know hey of course the
intangibles are important but the
ability to carry the football team when
the team is not maybe playing up to
their capabilities or you have injuries
and things like that and you mentioned a
great point with the los angeles rams
game man the cowboys weren't playing
good dak prescott made plays in that
football game to keep them competitive
to give them a chance really in the
fourth quarter to win that football game
it was all on deck and there was a
number of moments like that in the last
seven or eight weeks of the season to
where i changed my tune about deck
prescott about what i really thought he
was too uh so i'm with you on that and i
think both players wence and prescott
are phenomenal young talents and uh
franchise guys that we're gonna see
around for a while let's move on to a
couple of others we got six more to get
to marcus mariota and jameis winston
pick number two pink number one
respectively in the 2015 draft both
entering that final year of their rookie
contracts fifth year option 20.8 million
for each this year amy adams strunk the
owner of the titans has said she hopes
mariota can become the franchise
quarterback meaning he isn't now jameis
winston it's clear they're taking a
wait-and-see approach which of those
guys if any gets a long-term deal okay
i'm gonna say marcus mariota does not
get a long-term deal i just have not
seen enough you know as far as just pure
quarterback play for me to go oh marcus
mariota's the future and the titans are
in good hands you know talk about
another guy with the injury bug he's
been hurt just about every year of his
career and how to battle things so
that's one issue two it's very few and
far between and games where we look at
and go oh marcus mariota played really
well last week he had last year that
game against the new england patriots
where we all went damn this is why they
picked this guy number two but then you
know we go through three or four weeks
where we don't see him do anything
either i always come back to this with
him i think he's a a athlete who plays
quarterback instead of a quarterback
who's a good athlete so i'm gonna say no
there jameis winston's an interesting
one i do think he's set up for success
with the talent he has around him and a
bruce aryans but
gosh i got to see it to believe it i got
on and off the field and everything that
goes with it so if you made me pick one
right now i'm going to say neither one
of them gets a long-term deal i favored
jameis moore to get it but i gotta see
it to believe it before i put that stamp
of approval on it
i agree with you and i still think
jameis winston has that genetic defect
where he tries to do more than he's
physically capable of doing i remember
seeing it in college in that game
against oregon he's good for one of
those maybe every other game where
you're like jameis what the hell are you
doing and i know it's because i've been
there i've done that i've tried to do
things in the limited athletic capacity
that i have that go well beyond that
limited capacity you just end up out of
control because you think you can do
more than what your body can do right
and i don't think bruce arians coaches
that out of him all right andy dalton
quietly entering the last year of his
contract philip rivers not as quietly in
the last year of his and he seems to be
at peace with the idea that there may
not be another contract for the chargers
which of those guys if either gets a new
deal okay i'm gonna say andy dalton no i
think this is the last year of the andy
dalton era in in cincinnati in fact i
wouldn't be shocked if they got off to a
slow start that we saw ryan finley maybe
come in there at some point during this
year and they try him out their
fourth-round pick out of north carolina
state so i say no on dalton phillip
rivers i'm going to say he does get a
deal if he decides he wants to play but
i think it'll be a one or a two year
deal similar to what we saw like a drew
brees do you know last offseason
something along those lines but i think
it's coming to an end for phillip rivers
like i said yesterday there was a few
moments last year at the end of the
season where i was a little concerned
with the way the ball came out of his
hand lack of pop things like that but i
still think he's done enough there that
he warrants at least one more one-year
deal or a two-year deal
and i agree with you on both of those
although it's funny when we look at what
phillip rivers is saying now he said
almost the exact same thing four years
ago he got his contract and the charges
i think the challenge is if you let
philip rivers go who takes over for him
i wouldn't be surprised if he gets a one
or a two year band-aid because they're
going to want to develop somebody not
just draft somebody and throw him in
remember they had drew brees while they
had right phillip rivers under contract
and i think they prefer to have a baton
handing instead of tell one guy see you
later and then oh god what are we going
to do next all right last two
one guy's under contract for two years
well they both are yeah one's entering
the last year of his rookie contract but
he's got the fifth year option so cam
newton of the panthers jared goff of the
rams which if either gets that long-term
contract to go beyond 2020. okay i think
cam newton definitely gets it uh you
know again i think cam newton's a
special special football player he's the
best player in the history of the
carolina panthers franchise i'm gonna go
out there and say that right now uh and
you know again a guy that the stats
don't tell the whole picture with cam
newton the amount of pressure and the
things you have to prepare for to defend
him on a weekly basis is really the
beauty of what he brings to the table i
think they pay him jared goff is one
that's fascinating i'm on the fence
there i am a little bit where i want to
see another good year listen i think a
lot of jared goss success you've heard
me say this before i think is more
predicated on a really good offensive
play caller and game plan designer with
a lot of talent around him too you know
i haven't necessarily been like awed by
jared goff and his physical abilities
and what he brings to the table on a
weekly basis there have been a few
moments here or there but i think if you
made me pick i'm gonna say he gets his
contract extension too i don't know if i
necessarily agree with it but i think
he's a california kid the rams have been
successful they're building something in
la and i think the public pressure will
be too much to sign him because i still
think they're going to be a good team
this year so i think in the end they're
going to be stuck with jared goff
whether they want to be or not
see i think that's the one guy that we
really need to watch out for sean mcvay
saying i think i can do better i can
find someone better i can find someone
who i want not someone who i inherited
and when you i that that play in the
super bowl when brandon cooks was wide
open goff didn't see it goff didn't plan
for it and then when he finally did see
it he didn't throw the ball effectively
to get it done so i count do i count
four for you you've got mario to know
winston no dalton no and rivers no is
that right no i said rivers would get
that like like you said the one-year
candidate two-year band-aid type of
thing right so we're right at two and a
half because we're no on mariota and
dalton and with winston we don't know so
the over under two and a half so it's a
push i think we agree on that yeah two
and a half yeah sure yeah i think that's
a fair number i think cam newton will
get something too you know along the
lines of maybe a three or a four year
deal when his comes comes up uh but yeah
the interesting one is jared goff
the wild card there is the new owner
david tepper what's he going to want to
do with cam newton and and is cam newton
going to be healthy they they say he
will be but he still isn't throwing yet
after his latest shoulder procedure
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports